what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here so I'm sure you noticed I've been
gone for the week I went on a trip to
Colorado which was beautiful is my first
time away from YouTube for a solid week
and the entire time I've done YouTube
and it was nice to get away I had an
amazing time with the girlfriend gotta
meet her whole family they're all very
lovely people spend a ton of time in
nature oh my god it was so relaxing I
felt like I got a decomposed deep
compressed that keeps saying decompose
decompress I was able to unplug from the
internet except for Instagram I post it
on there follow me at the Greg Alba
shameless plug so yeah it was nice to
get away from social media this entire
week Game of Thrones hasn't been ruined
for me the defenders hasn't been ruined
for me I'm gonna be covering that this
week so for the next few days I'm just
doing a lot of catching up haven't been
scanning posts I haven't been reading
comments I haven't been watching other
youtubers videos and I also wanted to
say thank you to my best friend my
brother John Humphrey who was moving in
with me next week actually he kept the
channel live while I was away I haven't
seen anything he's posted yet but I do
know you guys have been incredibly
supportive towards him so thank you all
for showing John your support and thank
you John for being my brother anyway
yeah it's just a quick update gonna be
catching up on the defenders gonna watch
Game of Thrones later today with John
but on my way back my friend Andrew
Gordon from the movie source Channel I'm
sure some of you guys have seen him
before
he texted me this article from deadline
talking about the new joke or origin
movie I was thinking of talking about it
last night but honestly the road trip
back was 22 hours long I only got about
an hour of shut-eye so it was just very
exhausted but I decided to read a couple
of articles and I found this story very
intriguing so I thought when getting
back to the swing of things of filming
this will be the first thing I talk
about Grenon I know you guys probably
just want some reactions but hey I'm
gonna do what I want to do so I'm sure a
lot of people have already done videos
on this topic but WB is developing a
joker origin tale with todd phillips the
director of the hangover due date
old-school supposedly helming this film
and like I said I read a couple of
articles one article said Martin
Scorsese will be producing this another
article said he might be producing it I
don't know which one to go off of but
for the sake of this video I'll act as
if Martin Scorsese is producing it as if
he is holy moly Batman that is freakin
insane even if he's not directing just
producing that's really
and the other kicker to this
announcement is that it will not be
directly linked to the DCU lineage it
will be its own standalone movie not
having to worry about any tie ins to
other films and that information alone
got me very excited if you're a
dedicated follower of this channel
you've probably heard me say several
times before now I want comic book
movies especially like the marble in the
DC films to branch out and start doing
their own standalone movies or own solo
movies I don't have to worry about being
linked to their specific cinematic
universe I know I've said several times
that I've wanted a Batman year one
adaptation that doesn't have to be
directly linked to the DC EU films just
its own standalone film that could
probably be on an even lower budget
because in comic books alone there are
so many different interpretations
iterations and timelines and I thought
this idea of Hollywood acting on
standalone movies that don't have to be
linked to the other comic book movies
would be something they do way later
down the road but I think WB decided to
do it at a jumping-off point with the
Joker tale is actually a really good
idea however a lot I don't want let's
face it a lot of negativity can be said
about doing this I mean a big part of
what makes the Joker such an intriguing
character is that we don't know too much
about his backstory yes I know the Jack
Nicholson one had an origin in it I know
The Killing Joke comic book is one of
the definitive origins of the Joker in
terms of cinema though with not spending
too much time on how the Joker became
the Joker is a big part of the mystery
element to what the Joker does and who
he is so with that being said because
this is not connected to the DC EU
timeline it wouldn't affect any other
future installments that feature the
Joker as the primary or side antagonist
because this would be a totally separate
tale with him being a protagonist so
bottom line if you're gonna do a joker
origin tale I think it would be best to
not have it be connected to any of the
movies where he would be a villain or a
side villain such as the upcoming
Suicide Squad sequel or the Harley Quinn
spin-off and speaking of those films
sure Leto will obviously not be playing
the Joker in this standalone film and I
think it's gonna be a very interesting
time for the internet when this Joker
origin tale comes out because you know
there's gonna be a comparison game a lot
of people didn't like the Joker that
Jared Leto did a lot of people did liked
him
so watching people debate over who they
prefer is gonna be very
fascinator so now on to the filmmakers
behind this project todd phillips as a
director and the co-writer of this story
when I first heard todd phillips my
first thought was what why him then I
was thinking about some of his films and
I realized I hadn't seen war dogs yet so
before I passed out last night I saw
that on HBO go they had war dogs so I
decided to watch it about 20 to 30
minutes into watching this movie the
choice for Todd Phillips to be directing
the joke or origin tale just made a lot
more sense I've seen most of this guy's
movies I think I've seen all of them
actually and after due date and to
Hangover Part 3 while I really didn't
like either one of those films
especially The Hangover 3 I did see that
Todd Phillips was trying to make this
transition from just a comedy slapstick
kind of goofball comedic director into a
more serious filmmaker if you will due
date had a lot more drama in it than I
expected The Hangover Part 3 was pretty
much a thriller that had some dark
comedy infused into it I feel like Todd
Phyllis has been having a hard time
finding the right blend between doing
the comedy films he's known for and that
I'm sure the studio wants him to do and
then infusing deeper elements so I
watched were dogs last night
I didn't love the film and I didn't hate
the film either I thought it was decent
what I did see though was more of that
transition Todd Phillips has been trying
to me and the number one thing I kept
thinking while I was watching this film
pretty much within the first 10 minutes
I was thinking this the war dog style
and direction evidently heavily inspired
by Martin Scorsese films a lot of
directors want to be Martin Scorsese and
Todd Phillips was clearly doing that
with the war dogs moved the way the
editing was done the tone that was being
struck up the angles the overall
direction was just very Scorsese heavy
now war dogs never reached that level
for me Ron I felt like this was a great
film this feels like a really good
Scorsese s type of movie I never reached
that for me but I really did respect the
ambitions he had and at the end of the
day he came out with a pretty decent
dark comedy that explores criminal
activity so then I thought about Martin
Scorsese producing the Joker movie I
felt way more confident about Todd
Phillips actually directing this film
because he clearly drew inspiration from
Scorsese for war dogs and after reading
in both articles that this Joker origin
tale is supposed to be a
grounded hard-boiled crime drama that's
gonna be set in the 80s of Gotham City
that sounds really cool and they're
looking to have that kind of feel of
Scorsese classics like taxi driver
Raging Bull and the King of Comedy it
started making me feel like Todd
Phillips might actually be the right man
for the job I'm not a hundred percent
confident but after really thinking
about it I'm like 80 to 90 percent
confident and talk Phillips doing this
actually I really don't know how the
rest of the internet is responding I
don't know what anyone else on YouTube
has said I haven't read a single comment
on any of these articles I have no idea
what people are thinking about Todd
Phillips directing this film this is
just my own personal opinion but after
watching The Hangover Part 3 and war
dogs two films where I felt he was way
more interested in making a thriller
than giving in to the comedy elements
that people would expect from him I
thought this would be a great
opportunity for him to make a period
piece crime thriller if you look at
films like lights out and Annabel
creation two films directed by David
Sandberg and produced by James Wan David
Sandberg direction is very similar to
James Wan and I feel that having James
Wan on those films as a creative
producer helps smooth out and develop
those horror movies into mean really
good horror films so likewise I could
see a similar situation happening for
Todd Phillips and Martin Scorsese
producing the film that Todd Phillips is
directing and they see Joker movie
clearly 80 Scorsese film inspired and of
course yeah these people gardening I'm
back day one in a row oh you mother
Bobby Scorsese is a producer that's
creatively involved I can see this film
actually working cuz I think this is
just what Todd Phillips has been wanting
to do I feel like with a director like
Todd Phillips if he's actually able to
just commit to the film he actually
wants to make he can turn out with a
pretty damn good movie he does have
style he is good with comedy and with
this movie being about the Joker you're
gonna need at least some dark comedy
elements in here which he is pretty good
at doing and this Joker movies gonna be
a period piece in the 80s war dogs while
it only took place about a decade ago it
did explore the specific time at which
it took place and Todd Phillips also
directed one of my favorite comedies of
all time Starsky and Hutch which
explored the 70s and I thought I did a
really good job with that movie so while
I haven't loved the directors latest
films if he's able to make the kind of
Phil
he really wants to me because I highly
doubt that even though Todd Phillips is
a director I doubt anybody wants to see
a typical Todd Phillips comedy and if
this film is a success in terms of
critical reception and box office
reception
it could be monumental in shifting the
directions not entirely but in some
cases for comic book films and just
allowing Todd Phillips to become a whole
new kind of director and ask for who
should play the Joker I have no idea no
no clue I'm not even going to theorize
right now and maybe I'll do a video on
that later but who do you guys think
should play the Joker who do you think
should play the Joker
young Joker Tom Holland Tom Hardy tom
Felton Thomas Haden Church put your
comments down below I'm happy to be back
filming people miss you guys you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification valve follow me at the greg
alba and not the real rejects got all
the social media in the description box
follows everywhere and patreon.com slash
the real rejects thank you all have a
good day